What type of content should you make
that makes the most money? Not
necessarily gets the most reach. And so,
I've hit grand total 3 billion
impressions last year. We gained over 4
and 1/2 million subscribers. And we did
that making 35,000 pieces of content.
And just to give some validity to the
Mikey money part, we did over $106
million in sales in a single weekend at
my book launch. And a big reason for
that was because of the content
strategy. And so, I want to outline high
value, high ROI content strategy, which
I think is different than what the vast
majority of people are telling you to
do. FYI, I'm also going to show you our
behind-the-scenes data of the videos
that made the most views. That one's
public. And more importantly, the videos
that made the most money. And guess
what? They're not the same. Number one
is we have to answer the question like
why do you make content to begin with?
If you are somebody who makes content to
sell as a media company, meaning you
want to sell sponsorships and things
like that, then you indirectly want to
get buyers because you're getting buyers
for your advertisers who are paying you
dollars for ad spots, right? But the
vast majority of time, advertisers don't
know how to properly price media. And
so, they basically just go off of
audience and views. And so, when that's
the case, you are incentivized to just
get as many views as possible cuz that's
the business model. But the vast
majority of people who are making
content are not trying to build media
businesses. They're usually trying to
build businesses and use media as a way
to get customers. And so, if that's you,
then pay attention. So, number one, I
remember when I had my biggest belief
broken around this is there was a girl,
lady,
uh who had less than uh 5,000 or less
than 6,000 followers on Instagram. And
she was doing over a million dollars a
year just from that. And I was like,
this is crazy. When I looked at her
account, she was getting like nine
likes, 18 likes, 20 likes on a big post.
And all she talked about was being a
registered dietitian. And how to bill
insurance as a registered dietitian. So,
there was nothing about weight loss,
nothing about about the the how to how
to be literally just billing. And it was
so niche. I was like, how's this making
money? But the thing is is that I can
guarantee you that of the 5 or 6,000
people who were following her, almost
all of them were registered dietitians
who were trying to bill a church better,
right? And so, I decided to put this to
the test. And so, I've done two tests on
this in my career. One I did, uh I think
18 months ago, where for one quarter we
made more top of funnel stuff. Cuz the
idea was if we make bigger, broader
content, we're going to get more overall
people, and then even though it'll be a
smaller percentage, it'll be a bigger
absolute number of the people in that
bigger net that are going to be kind of
whales or our customers, right? And so,
after doing that quarter, what was
really interesting is that we we broke
all of our views records. Uh and so, all
the numbers, like all the vanity metrics
were going up. The problem was book
sales were down, leads were down,
portfolio company applications were
down. And so, all of the the metrics
that I care about for the business were
down, but all of the metrics that other
people talk about for media were up. And
so, I had to make a decision of like
what kind of, you know, creator am I?
And for me, I'm about the business. Like
that is why I made it, right? That's why
I started doing this to begin with was
because it's a great way to build trust
with an audience, deliver value, and
just overall just grow. Now,
I then, because I apparently like to
learn the same lesson multiple times,
decided to do another version of this
more recently. So, I wanted to show you
something really, really cool. And so,
check this out.
Now, I almost never make content that's
not about business in general. And
that's just because like I like
business, and so that's what I make
content about, okay? And it's also where
I think I have authority. I don't have
authority in other spaces, I don't
really talk about it so much. Now, these
six videos that you see here are the top
most viewed videos over the last
quarter. All right? And you can see 1.2,
1 million, uh you know, 800k, 500k,
500k, 3 350, okay? So, these are most
viewed videos. So, what's interesting
about these videos is they made
no sales.
Think about how wild that is.
Zero. None. Now, what are these videos
all about? All of these are, I would
say, beginner oriented. And that's
because I have a little bit of a um
a personal mission on that side, which
is
like the reason I write these books
is because I always wanted someone to
show me how to do things better than I
feel like I got help on. And so I try
to make this content to help somebody
else out. Um and for whatever reason, it
makes me feel like I'm making some sort
of impact, which when I'm alone at night
looking at the ceiling, it makes me feel
a little better. All right. That being
said, from a business perspective, let's
look at which videos actually generate
the most revenue.
So, number one most revenue video. This
was a 270,000 1,000 video. And I'll tell
you this, when I made this video, I was
like, this video is so good. I was like,
I love it. It was my favorite
video of the whole quarter. Uh which by
the way, you should check it out. I
think it's awesome. But, it's
purely about like how where the money
is, how to make it, how to segment
customers, and like the real stuff that
makes money in a business. But, by its
very nature, it tends to talk to people
who already have businesses, right? And
not just like smaller businesses, enough
that you can like segment customers,
right? And so, it's by definition going
to have a smaller viewership because
only 9% of people in the United States,
for example, have businesses. And of
those 9%, that's people who like have
LLCs, including like your hair stylist
and your nail salon girl. To be clear,
nothing wrong with that. It's absolutely
a sole proprietor business, and there's
going to be more of them. But, in terms
of what this is going to impact more,
and it does work for that business as
well, but they might not have the data
to to really utilize it. And so, even of
businesses that are doing over, let's
say, $100,000 a year, all of a sudden
you take that 9%, cut it by probably
2/3, right? So, it's a very, very small
percentage people who the content that I
make at the most viable level applies
to. Real quick, I'm going to show you
the exact 10-stage roadmap from zero to
100 million plus
that less than 1% of companies finish
I've now done multiple times, and so I
can say with a lot of confidence that
these are the stages, as head count
increases, that you need to get through.
And I broke each of these down by eight
different functions of the business,
what the constraint feels like, like
what are the symptoms of it when you're
going through it, and then what steps we
actually took to graduate. And we've
done this across software, physical
products, uh service businesses, brick
and mortar, all of this and it works.
And it's my gift to you. It's absolutely
free. And so, the link's in the
description, but you just go
acquisition.com/roadmap.
Just enter your info and it'll spit it
right back to you all free. And so,
these other two videos
were episodes of what we're calling Cash
Cows, which we're going to have a new
version coming out soon,
uh that we're calling something
secretive, which I'll tell you later.
But, this is me going deep with
businesses that are all multi-million
dollar businesses, right? And so, these
have, you know, 100,000 views, 250,000
views. So, like, not super high view
counts, but these are the ones that
generated the most revenue. And so, the
reason this is so important is that the
algorithm will give you the wrong signal
for your business. And so, the algorithm
will tell you what the most people like,
not the most valuable people like. And
so, if you think about it, I would
honestly encourage you to just watch the
51 to 1 rule video because it actually
takes this idea of where, like, if you
transpose money against population, you
realize visually how disproportionate it
is. And so, you're trying to fight for
this 50% of the audience that has $2,
whereas the other 50% of the audience
has $98, right? A lot more. And so, this
is where the mistake is happening and
people are taking the views as their
signal for what their media strategy is
going to be. And as somebody who's made
this mistake multiple times because it's
hard to it's hard to pull yourself back
because it's like, wait, but what if I
have a video that is generate revenue
and it's the right type of video and it
gets a lot of views? It's like, well,
that's Nirvana, right? That's what we
call qualume, right? That's quality and
volume put together. But, if I had to
pick between both videos, I would
obviously want to pick the one that
generates revenue. So, then the next
question is, okay, well, are there
videos that are called, you know, top of
funnel, that are videos that kind of
bring people into your world, and then,
uh videos that kind of like middle
funnel, bottom of funnel, that kind of
convert those people. And so, I think
the answer is yes and no. We want to
make videos that apply in terms of value
equally to people at all stages in
business, which is different than only
having something that's valuable for
somebody who makes over a certain
amount. And so, if I'm going broad, I
still want what I'll call vertical
value. I want the starter and the $100
million guy to both be able to get value
from this video. Whereas, if I'm talking
about how to go from 1 to 10, I know
that video is going to absolutely tank,
but it's going to bring people who are
between 1 and 10 million or looking to
get to 10 or 20 and beyond, and that is
going to generate significantly more
revenue because they have more buying
power. Even if the numbers are smaller.
And so, I would encourage you to do a
little bit of a challenge. And so, on
that point of this verticalization of
value,
this four best revenue generating video
is kind of a good example of that, which
is
if I'm talking about how the 1% actually
think about money, people who are the 1%
can still get a lot of value in terms of
like what I'm talking about in the
video. And also, somebody who's brand
new could get value from the video as
well. And so, that's kind of a video
that's like it generates dollars, but it
also gets views. And see, it has it has
more views than the top 1 2 3 do, right?
And all the way at the end there, that
video is literally just a straight Q&A
for service businesses,
but it's still generating the sixth most
revenue out of all videos that we made
over the quarter. So,
this is my challenge to you. If you are
afraid of making kind of deeper, more
advanced content, do not be. And do not
think that when you get low views, you
are somehow, you know, disserving your
audience. You're serving a different
audience. And the algorithm has gotten
so good at transcribing and knowing
exactly what you're talking about that
they will serve it to only those people.
But you have to remember that there's
far fewer of the most valuable people
than there are of the least valuable
people. And so, if you have any concepts
of business strategy, the idea is you
want to serve you either have a business
that you want to serve everyone for as
low cost as possible, then that's a
Walmart strategy. Nothing wrong with
that. It's a very hard business to run,
but you can absolutely do it if you
start with that day one. Or what a lot
of people who get into services do
because it's significantly less scalable
is they go for the higher end of the
market because that's where the money
is. If you want to get more buyers in
your content, you have to make videos
for your buyers. And if you don't know
who your buyers are, you look at your
customer base, you look at the people
who spent the most money, you look at
the top 20%, look at the common factors
they have, look at what messages and
problems they had, and then create
messaging and video topics that solve
the problems that the people with the
most money in your audience had, and
then make content about that. Be
prepared to see your view counts go
down, your subscriber counts go down,
but your sales go up. Yeah, and from a
tracking perspective, we just put UTMs
um on the links that were below the
descriptions in the videos, and I'd make
CTAs inside the videos to take the next
step of whatever kind of lead magnet,
whatever.
Um
and that is how we could see on the back
end how that translated into revenue for
the business.